Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
So Bill and Melinda Gates's annual letter
just came out, and it really is my favorite
letter of the year...with apologies to the
birthday card I get every year from my insurance
agent.
You should read the whole thing, link below.
But it predicts that in the next 15 years,
the lives of the world's poorest people will
become dramatically better.
All right.
So even though hundreds of millions of people
have emerged from absolute poverty in the
last 25 years, and even though child mortality
has been cut by half, and even though more
kids than ever have access to vaccinations,
we still kind of live in two worlds.
In one world, fewer than 1% of kids die before
the age of 5, almost no one gets malaria,
very few children are denied access to vaccines
because of lack of refrigeration, and serious
malnutrition in children is extremely uncommon.
And then, we have the other world.
In that one, 1.5 million kids die every year
from diseases that could be easily prevented
by vaccines.
There are like 200 million cases of malaria
every year, and more than 25% of kids are
stunted due to malnutrition, which can lead
to cognitive problems and all kinds of other
health issues.
And in this world, kids are far less likely
to go to school, or to learn how to read,
especially if they're girls.
And all of that is totally unacceptable.
It's also unnecessary.
So global child mortality has dropped by half
in the last 25 years, and the Gates letter
argues that in the next 15 years, it can drop
by half again.
And this is achievable without expensive specialists
or new medical procedures.
How?
First, breast feeding.
Infants who are breastfed for 6 months are
14 times more likely to survive.
Second, access to cheap injectable antibiotics,
which could save 300,000 kids a year.
Then you've got inexpensive hand-pumped oxygen
masks, which could prevent a third of infant
deaths.
Fourth, drying the baby and offering skin-to-skin
contact to keep it warm.
And lastly, keeping the umbilical cord free
from infection.
This can actually be done with an ingredient
found in my mouthwash.
Literally.
Before moving on here, quick reminder that
cutting infant mortality does not lead to
population explosions in the long run.
In fact, quite the opposite.
The Gates letter also talks about a bunch
of other investments and innovations that
will improve the lives of poor people, like
access to mobile banking and better farming
practices and online education tools.
And I just wanna imagine for a moment what
that world would look like.
Enough food would be produced in Africa to
feed every African.
The 2.5 billion people without a bank account
would be able to save and dramatically simplify
their economic lives with access to mobile
banking.
Girls would have far better educational opportunities,
dramatically reducing the gender gap in literacy.
Polio, river blindness, and guinea worm diseases
that kill or disable tens of millions of people
wouldn't even exist anymore.
And half the kids who are gonna die today
would not die.
In short, the world's people would be healthier,
and better educated, and more productive.
And that would be good for all of us, because
here's the thing: we do not actually live
in two worlds.
It sometimes feels like we do, not just because
no one in my neighborhood has kids who are
stunted due to malnutrition, but because no
one I follow on Tumblr or Twitter or Instagram
has kids who are.
Hank, the reach of my online life can feel
infinite, but it isn't.
And that inevitably creates an empathy gap.
As Bill and Melinda put it in the letter,
there is overwhelming evidence that people
care about others who are suffering when they
can see that suffering.
But too often we can't see it, not because
people in the developing world are silent,
but because we're not good at listening to
them.
We're far better at listening to voices that
feel closer, that we can find on Tumblr or
Twitter--people who feel like "us."
But the way we imagine us must include people
living in poverty, because there is just the
one world.
And when we start to pay attention to problems
that seem distant and foreign, we often find
that they actually aren't.
They're human problems; they're us problems.
Hank, I think the coolest thing about the
Gates letter this year is that they give us
the opportunity to learn to listen better
and more broadly by signing up to be something
they call a Global Citizen.
The idea is that if we become more informed
about the issues facing people around the
world, we will naturally become more engaged.
I think that's brilliant, and I hope it allows
me, at least, to learn to listen better.
So I hope you'll join me in signing up, link
in the doobly-doo.
Hank, by the way, I also hope that we're still
making videos in 15 years so we can discuss
which of the Gates letter predictions came
true and which didn't.
But before then--in fact, significantly before
then--I will see you on Friday.